when we interviewed Kenneth Copeland and
we had some some questions we wanted to
ask him about his private jet use he got
really angry at me he flirted with me he
tried a couple of different tactics the
job of a journalist is to hang in there
and ask the questions you can't control
if they run away from you or what they
say to you but you can control your
demeanor and you can control the
questions and that's what I did
I'm Lisa Guerrero and today I'm
unfiltered if I could describe Who I am
in just a few words it would be I'm a
journalist a host and activist and
basically I chase bad guys the first
time I recognized Beauty was seeing my
mom and the kind of attention that she
got when we were out in public and I
would notice people it's literally
double taking my mother and now as an
adult I look at pictures of her and I
realize oh my god she's a beautiful
woman and she's physically beautiful
she's so beautiful she was
[Music]
I was born in Chicago and my dad at the
time was working for the Salvation Army
as a social worker and he married my mom
who was an immigrant from Chile and the
two of them moved to San Diego when I
was little so by the time I was three or
four we lived in San Diego and a small
neighborhood called Lemon Grove and my
parents didn't make much money but I
didn't know what that meant because I
was completely surrounded by their love
constantly and I have a little brother
named Richard and the four of us just
had this really amazing happy life until
I was eight years old and that's when my
mom was diagnosed with cancer and so I
lost my mom at eight and so that changed
[Music]
of course my life and the trajectory of
my life and that's kind of the lens
through which I view my childhood before
eight years old and after I didn't have
a mom to kind of teach me the ways of
beauty but I had an amazing dad who
loved me and didn't care what I looked
like and so I kind of got that message
that it doesn't matter what you look
like you don't need make-up to be
beautiful you don't have to shop at
expensive places to look good your
beauty is something that's inside of you
and not on the outside of you so my dad
really taught me that and gave me an
enormous amount of strength and I kind
of came away from that part of my life
thinking that it kind of doesn't matter
what I look like it's more about you
know my dad putting me in sports and how
my body works as an athlete not am i
cute two boys so I got a very different
perspective growing up I think than
other girls did and for that I really
think I was given a huge blessing so I
was born lisa Coles my dad's last name
is Coles and because my mom died when I
was eight I was missing something I felt
disconnected to her because she wasn't
physically here and I realized in my 20s
I just felt like I look more latina and
I feel like I am connected to the Latino
side of my family that was an actress
before I became a broadcaster and my
first acting job was for a show and
Aaron Spelling show called Sunset Beach
and they asked you when you sign your
contract
what is the name you want to be put on
the credits and it was the first time I
said that this is it this is my chance
to be a Guerrero I was credited as Lisa
Guerrero Kohl's on Sunset Beach every
time I credit would come up I'd be so
excited moving forward after Sunset
Beach I became Lisa Guerrero across the
board so I am Lisa Guerrero ya metal
feel great like I said I did a lot of
work to get raised and get out of my
shot sorry when I think about my acting
career recently the most fun I've had
was in Moneyball because they created
this character that was based on me so I
basically got to play myself and it was
really fun because I had been in locker
rooms for years as a sportscaster in
real life and then to be able to be in a
movie with Brad Pitt and these amazing
actors I'm really proud of Moneyball and
then it was nominated for an Academy
Award so that was fun
I'm Lisa Guerrero at the Inside Edition
you've got my speaker right there you
just broke into our car my acting
background has 100% helped me as a
journalist when I go undercover because
I get one shot you get one shot at a
confrontation which we call unscheduled
interviews you don't get to say oh by
the way I said that wrong can I say that
again cuz the bad guy will already be
down the block or then the jig is up so
it's really important for me to get it
right the first time people ask me all
the time how are you not recognized so
when we go undercover there's a couple
weird things psychologically you are not
expecting me to come into your life or
your business even if you watch me on
Inside Edition there's no way you're
gonna think that you're actually gonna
see somebody on TV in your real life so
first of all just the element of
surprise helps me if I'm going
undercover you'll see that I all try to
like change my hair a little bit I'll
wear glasses once in a while I've worn a
wig one time I wore a latex mask as an
old lady so I do use disguises once in a
while but I think what I try to do is
just put together a character that
people aren't expecting to see in real
life so I have been recognized a couple
of times even once with a wig on it was
like a blonde wig a bob I looked like a
real housewife of Orange County and this
dude still recognized me he's like
you're Lisa Guerrero aren't you and it's
my producer and I were like really how
do you recognize me like this I swear to
god I look like a real housewife
Orange County look like I was gonna pick
up the kids in a minivan
from their private school and he
recognized me was weird you said that
you don't like to fly commercial because
you don't want to get into a tube with a
bunch of demons do you really believe
that human beings are demons no I do not
and don't you ever say I did when we
interviewed Kenneth Copeland for a story
we did on private jets and donations to
these televangelists we worked so hard
to try to get him he really tries to
avoid doing any kind of interview with
mainstream media and so it's really hard
to get him of course we had called
beforehand to try to get a sit-down
interview he said no his people would
not let him do a sit-down interview with
us so that's when we go to them and in
this case we went to Branson Missouri we
knew he was going to be there to do some
preaching and some seminars and we had
some some questions we wanted to ask him
about his private jet use and so for
several days we couldn't get an
opportunity to get close enough to be
near him he went right from this you
know door right to a waiting SUV and
then he would be you know driven off to
wherever and we couldn't get him finally
on the third day we found out that he
was showing up to do the seminar and we
found out a place that would be close
enough that when he came out of the door
I would run up and ask him for an
interview how are you sir we just like
to ask you about why you don't want to
fly commercial why have you said that
you won't fly commercial you said that
it's like getting into a tube with a
bunch of demons and that's what we did
on the very last day and here's what's
really funny about that interview I
hadn't taken a shower in a couple of
days because we had been on surveillance
for hours and hours and hours and it was
time to wash my hair my producer said ok
this morning is a good time to do it cuz
we don't we don't know where he is we
don't think he's gonna show up till
tonight so go back to your hotel take a
shower do whatever you need to do rest I
get back to my hotel you guys I'm in the
shower and I hear the phone ring
and I'm like there's no way there's no
way I reach my hand out and it's my
producer going he's here you need to get
back right now get in the car come right
you need to be here in five minutes come
back so I've got a full head of hair
like wet I jump out of the shower I grab
a sweatshirt and my wet hair I put back
in a ponytail which I never do on camera
for this a half a billion people have
seen it
billion with Abby I'm almost
unrecognizable because I hardly have any
makeup on and my hair is pulled back in
this low ponytail and on top of this
sweatshirt I just threw on a scarf so
you couldn't see I'm wearing a white
sweatshirt and it's just weird it
doesn't even look like me of all the
times to go viral it's crazy but ya know
we weren't expecting him to to stay on
there and to talk to me for so long but
he did how much money did you pay for
Tyler Perry's Gulfstream jet for example
well for example that's really none of
your business
but isn't the business of your donors
and when he did and he got really angry
at me and kind of he flirted with me he
tried a couple of different tactics
thank you lord help me many phrases to
get me from asking him the question that
I kept going back to which was did you
say you won't fly commercial because you
don't want to get into a tube with a
bunch of demons and is it fair to your
donors that you're spending millions of
dollars on private jets people are very
concerned about that comment chance your
inside division I love your eyes the job
of a journalist is to hang in there and
ask the questions you can't control if
they run away from you or what they say
to you but you can control your demeanor
and you can control the questions and
that's what I did
[Music]
I've been on camera my entire adult life
I have always felt a pressure to look
good on camera because of course
television is a visual medium but as
I've gotten older I've realized that I'm
never going to look 25 again and that's
okay it's okay to have experience it's
okay to have lines around your eyes and
age spots and it's okay not to be
perfect perfect is boring what's more
interesting is experience and a sense of
humor a sense of confidence as I've
gotten older I've really embraced the
fact that it doesn't have to do with
physical beauty all the time that
there's something really compelling and
beautiful about confidence and kindness
and and just being a good loving person
that's just beautiful
I feel good about not wearing makeup
right now because this is a well-lit
room first of all people have seen me
looking really really good so what are
you gonna do my hair is looking alright
I guess I just I don't care anymore I'm
55 it doesn't matter I feel good about
me
[Music]